carla puede llenar con refrescos 5 vasos
cada 20 segundos completa la tabla con
razones equivalentes y en esta tabla
podemos ver que carla me llenan 5 vasos
cada 20 segundos una forma de pensarlo
es que la razón de vasos llenados por
segundo es de 5 a 20 y después nos piden
que calculemos el tiempo en el que carla
va a llenar dos vasos así que pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrar la respuesta
veamos para pasar de 5 vasos a 12 vasos
porque tenemos que multiplicar bueno
tenemos que multiplicar por 12 puntos
por 12 quintos porque observan 5 por 12
quintos esto es lo mismo que 12 este con
este se va entonces tenemos que
multiplicar el tiempo por la misma
constante para obtener el número de
segundos a 20 lo voy a multiplicar
también por 12 puntos para así obtener
la cantidad de segundos que se tardarán
en llenar 12 vasos y bueno 20 por 12
quintos
dos quintos esto va a ser igual a bueno
20 entre 5 es 4 y 4 por 20 es 48 48
segundos entonces carles llenaran 12
vasos en 48 segundos muy bien ahora qué
podemos hacer cuando nos preguntan
cuántos vasos llenaran en 44 segundos
bueno observa que estamos multiplicando
los segundos por bueno por 44 veinteavos
44 20 a vos entonces voy a multiplicar
por la misma cantidad para obtener la
cantidad de vasos que llenar a carla en
44 segundos
y me quedaría que 5 x 44 20 a vos esto
va a ser igual a bueno
5 x 44 es 220 ok y esto entre 20 me va a
quedar simplemente en 11 entonces
llenaran 11 vasos en 44 segundos hagamos
otro ejemplo trabajemos con este de aquí
la recta numérica doble muestra qué tan
lejos puede volar un colibrí en un
segundo aquí tenemos una recta numérica
doble y puedes ver que la razón de la
distancia que puede viajar un colibrí en
un segundo es de 13 metros o también lo
podemos escribir así es de 13 metros por
cada segundo en un segundo récord de 13
metros
después nos dicen completa la tabla para
mostrar la misma información que la
recta numérica doble así que por qué no
pausas el vídeo e intentas averiguar lo
bueno lo primero que se me ocurre es ver
en cuántos segundos el colibrí récord en
13 metros y para nuestra suerte es el
dato que nos dan observa esta recta
numérica doble dice que en un segundo el
colibrí récord de 13 metros por lo tanto
puedo poner aquí un segundo en esta
tabla muy bien ahora regresemos al mismo
caso de la tabla anterior habrá que ver
por qué constante estamos multiplicando
el 13 para obtener 39 y bueno si
observas 13 por 3 es 39 así que hay que
multiplicar el tiempo por la misma
cantidad
voy a multiplicar 1 por 3 y voy a
obtener 3 segundos
entre segundos recuerde 39 metros y de
manera similar para la otra fila voy de
1 a 10 así que estoy multiplicando por
10 y voy a hacer lo mismo para la
distancia
voy a multiplicar 13 por 10 para obtener
la distancia que va a recorrer el
colibrí en 10 segundos y 13 por 10 es
130 el colibrí recorre 130 metros en 10
segundos bien hagamos otro más hay 914
punto 4 milímetros en una yarda y hay 3
pies en una yarda cuantos milímetros hay
en un pie
bueno una forma de pensarlo es que
tenemos una razón de 900 14.4 en
milímetros por yarda
o también lo podemos ver como 900 14.4
milímetros por 3 pies ya que una yarda
es lo mismo que tres pies por lo tanto
si queremos saber en un pie cuantos
milímetros hay habrá que dividir esta
razón entre tres y bueno para eso
simplemente tengo que hacer la división
900 14.4 esto
entre 3 me va a dar bueno 3 cadáver en
93 veces tres por 39 así que el resto y
me quedan 0 y después bajo este 1 y
observan 3 no cabe ninguna vez en uno
entonces pongo 100 por tres es cero así
que lo voy a restar rápidamente y me
queda 1 y voy a bajar ahora este 4
y bueno tres caben cuatro veces el 14 4
por 3 es 12 entonces 14 menos 12 es
simplemente 2 y por último voy a bajar
este 4 pero antes voy a poner aquí un
punto decimal llegamos al punto decimal
bajo este 4 y para nuestra suerte 3 cabe
en 24 8 veces de manera exacta 8 por 3
es 24 y cuando hago la vista me quedan
simplemente 0 de lujo
entonces ya puedo decir que en un pie
hay 300 4.8 milímetros muy bien hagamos
un último ejemplo dice raúl compro una
libra de confeti por 12 pesos cuál es el
precio en pesos por onza recuerda hay 16
onzas en una libra pausa el vídeo e
intentar resolverlo
bien escribamos esto usando razones
sabemos qué 12 pesos vale una libra
entonces voy a escribir 12 pesos por
libra por otra parte sabemos que hay 16
onzas en una libra así que esto es lo
mismo que 12 pesos por 16 onzas es decir
podemos ver esto como una razón de 12 a
16 y si queremos saber el precio por una
onza entonces tengo que dividir esta
razón entre 16 y bueno 12 pesos entre 16
eso es lo mismo que 2 entre 16 que es lo
mismo que tres cuartos que tres cuartos
y lo podemos ver como 0.75 o 75 centavos
es decir una onza de confeti valen 75
centavos
y lo podemos escribir aquí valen 0.75
una onza de compete y ya con esto
acabamos